Yesterday we arrived at a very critical
junction in listing
the various invalidators of wudu.
Of course, the first, most holistic
invalidator of wudu, most general, and
most commonly known
is al-kharij min al-sabilayn. Anything
that comes out of the private parts.
Right? It's referred to in Arabic as a
sabeelain,
meaning the two paths. The two paths out
of the body, direct paths
out of the body.
So, the front and back private parts.
The second is deep sleep.
And we had two questions.
Two issues to deal with.
The first was
how do you distinguish between deep
sleep and
light sleep? That's what we're going to
talk about today, inshallah.
But the issue we spoke about yesterday
was
why is it that deep sleep invalidates
your wudu?
However, light sleep does not.
Because when the author says
and no will mustaqil
min nawafil wudu.
Mafhum hadal hasr
and then no will ghair al mustaqil
[Arabic recitation]
al mu'allif.
When the author says deep sleep
invalidates your wudu, what's understood
from this, what's implied, is that light
sleep does not.
And that is exactly what he intended.
So, why is it that deep sleep breaks a
person's wudu, whereas light sleep does
not? We spoke about this yesterday in
in summary,
deep sleep or light sleep, the act of
sleeping itself does not break a
person's wudu.
Sleep does not directly affect a
Sleep is an indirect
invalidator of wudu. What does that
mean? Meaning sleep itself doesn't
invalidate the wudu,
but it is the lack of awareness that a
person is in
that when they fall asleep, they would
not know
if one of the other things that
invalidates a person's wudu happened
because they're in deep sleep.
So, we said
[Silence]
And so,
we said anything coming out of the two
private parts invalidates a person's
wudu.
If a person is in deep sleep, they are
no longer aware
of that which is coming out of their
private parts.
They are If something were to come out,
they would not know.
They would be none the wiser. And so,
for this reason,
we say
sleep does not invalidate a person's
wudu,
rather deep sleep because
sleep does not directly invalidate a
person's wudu, rather
it is
it is a gray area where when a person
falls into deep sleep, they can no
longer with any amount of certainty
say that they did not break their wudu.
This is why.
Second of all, most people do break
their wudu when they're sleeping.
Cuz when a person sleeps,
the body relaxes, the muscles relax, and
any gases that are in the stomach or the
belly, they start to come out.
And this is why Ali ibn Abi Talib radi
[Arabic recitation]
is the leash of the anus.
So, whoever falls asleep, then he is to
make wudu."
And in this understanding, now you see
why the scholars of fiqh have the
different opinions that they have with
regards to sleep.
So, for instance,
one opinion is the position that a
person sleeps in.
Says,
"If a person falls asleep sitting up,
not leaning on anything,
and and falls asleep, their wudu is
intact.
But if they lean on anything, then they
have to make wudu. Where are they
getting this from?
Where would a would a scholar, a jurist,
get this from? The answer is back to
what we said, "An nawmu
laysa naqidhan lil wudu bi dhatihi bi
[Arabic recitation]
naqdhil wudu."
So, he's saying, "Look, if a person is
sitting up,
and they're not leaning on anything,
it's impossible, physically,
this is the
train of thought. It's impossible,
physically, for any gases to escape the
body.
Therefore, if a person falls asleep
sitting up,
then their wudu would not be invalid.
And then they have evidences of this
from the Sunnah, from the companions
that we will speak about.
However, it's really not about the
position that a person is in,
rather, it is about the depth of sleep,
how deep one's sleep is.
And this takes us to our second
question. How can we distinguish between
deep and light sleep, and how do we
quantify
deep sleep? Because we have to be able
to say, "This is the
dividing line between light and deep
sleep." How do we know the difference?
The difference
is back to the essence of this issue,
and that is one's awareness.
Have you ever
fallen asleep, and then someone walks in
the room. They don't make any noise at
all, no noise.
A ninja walks into the room,
and then you wake up.
Right?
I think most of us have had this with
our dads.
You try to creep in the room for
something,
and you are super super super
quiet, but he wakes up by your mere
presence.
This is light sleep.
A person,
have you ever fallen asleep, but then
people are talking around you, and
you're still hearing what they're
saying?
This is light sleep.
The scholars of fiqh quantify light
sleep
as awareness of change to your body or
surroundings while you're in this state
of sleep. This is called light sleep
shara'an.
So, what is light sleep? Light sleep
is when a person falls asleep, but he is
aware of changes
to his body or to his surroundings
while he is sleeping. This is light
sleep.
But, if a person loses his awareness,
then a person is in deep sleep. And
everyone goes through the stage of light
sleep to get to deep sleep.
It's not possible
to go to deep sleep without light sleep
first, even if it's very brief, even if
you're really, really tired, your body
goes through stages of sleep. It doesn't
just drop asleep,
right?
You go through stages. First, you have
the tired,
the
you know,
release of melatonin in the brain. I'm
not a doctor, but melatonin in the
brain, the receptors start picking it
up, a person starts getting drowsy, they
start getting tired,
and then they go through different
stages to reach deep sleep.
One of the quantifiers of deep sleep is
that you dream.
If you are dreaming,
then you are in deep sleep.
And this is why the prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would fall asleep
and sleep at night after Isha,
as Ibn Abbas narrated, he would come
home, he would lay down where you had
this
set up from where you now
And he would sleep so deeply that you
could hear him snore.
Because when he would sleep, he would
have a light snore, alaihis salatu was
salam, which is a rather endearing
quality. So he would have a light snore
when he is sleeping.
And
then he would wake up
and make salah, not make wudu.
Why did he not make wudu?
Because his heart is awake.
the dis-
cription of the prophets
is that their eyes sleep, but their
hearts are always awake.
So
he would sleep, but he never loses
awareness of his spiritual state, and
wudu is a spiritual state.
And this is why it is the sunnah to make
wudu before going to bed. And if the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was in a state of janabah, and he was
not going to bathe before he goes to
sleep, he would bathe when he wakes up,
he would at least make wudu. And if he
didn't make wudu, he would at least make
tayammum before going to
sleep, sallallahu alaihi wasallam. And
he would always sleep with wudu. Why?
Yaqulu ibnul Qayyim fi tariqil hijratain
rahimahullah
annar ruh
tuqbad halan nawm
qabdan
asghar
al qabdatul akbar huwa indal mawt
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would make
as he is going to sleep before he goes
to sleep they are the words of a person
who is leaving this world.
Right? And this is why many of the of
God are whoever says this and then goes
to sleep and then dies in his sleep
Why because sleep is a minor death.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala takes
the soul when a person is sleeping but
it is not a complete detachment from the
body.
There is
still a connection between the body and
the soul but it is a very
it's a minor
disconnect.
And so the souls are in a spiritual
[Arabic recitation]
And so it is befitting
it is only befitting of the believer
that when he goes to sleep when his soul
is taken
for sleep it is in a state of wudu.
It is in a state of wudu to be taken by
Allah to be taken by Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala. And this is why he would always
make wudu before he goes to sleep. And
if he could not make wudu, then he or if
he chose not to make wudu, he would at
least make what? Tayamum.
Nas'al Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
an yu'allimana ma yanfa'una wa an
[Arabic recitation]